the United States has now officially
said we do not believe that the recent
surveillance balloons slash devices
tentatively believed to be from China
are evidence of intelligent aliens from
another planet solar system or Galaxy
even visiting us on Earth uh Joe Biden's
press secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre
making that statement during a press
briefing yesterday we addressed this
from the White House I know there have
been questions and and concerns about
this but there is no again no indication
of aliens or extraterrestrial activity
with these recent takedowns again there
is no indication of aliens or
terrestrial actors it's funny because
the Press Corps laughs
but just look online there are endless
gobs of people
convinced that this is a cover-up of
extraterrestrial encounters everybody
with these recent takedowns wanted to
make sure that the American people knew
that all of you knew that and it was
important for us to say that from here
because we've been sure Karine that's
just what you would say if you wanted to
cover it up hearing a lot about it
um
I'm just you know I loved E.T the movie
but I'm just gonna leave it there all
right the National Security council's
John Kirby also reiterated this and said
this is these are not aliens it's not
aliens folks the top officials of the
Pentagon when asked explicitly if uh
they were ruling out any kind of
extraterrestrial presence said they
weren't ruling anything out and yet at
the beginning of today's briefing albeit
with her usual winning smile uh Ms
Jean-Pierre seemed to rule out any
extraterrestrial activity I don't think
the American people need to worry about
aliens with respect to these craft
period I don't think there's any now
you heard what he said right I don't
think the American people need to worry
about aliens
with respect to these craft and there
are those who believe that Kirby
is very narrowly answering this question
and saying these are not
extraterrestrial aliens but that doesn't
mean that there aren't others now let's
talk a little bit about aliens this is
this is a very interesting topic I want
to expand on what I said during my
recent appearance with Anthony pompliano
when I was down in Florida one of the
appearances I did was with Anthony
pompliano and he asked me about aliens
it is really important to understand the
sheer vastness of the universe you've
got our galaxy The Milky Way hundreds of
billions of stars and then all of the
accompanying planets and so on and so
forth so I do have a very general view
that based on what we know about the
vastness of the universe
statistically I think the likelihood of
extraterrestrial life of some kind could
be bacterial could be intelligence I
don't know
I think the odds are high the
probability of that intelligent life
having already visited Earth I believe
is extraordinarily low and and the sort
of math of it is as follows you look at
the number of stars in the universe it's
astronomical 100 billion in our you know
own Milky Way alone with that number of
stars it is likely that at least some
planets would be capable of supporting
life so the conditions at least
theoretically for life are probably not
that rare if you look at all of the
planets that there are you then say okay
well on some fraction of those that
could support life
it doesn't seem super unlikely even if
it's a small percentage that life would
develop and so I do think that when you
consider all of that and the age of the
universe 13.8 billion years old that's a
lot of time for life to have evolved on
other planets as well
so I think it is likely given the laws
of physics and chemistry which appear to
be Universal and all these different
things it's likely that there is life on
other planets do I think it has reached
Earth in the form of a balloon or a
cylinder or you know humanoid four foot
tall aliens with obsessed with anal
probes uh it must be proctology must be
big on other planets I don't know that I
don't have any evidence for and then
when you look at you know the numerous
so-called UFO sightings over the years
we have a lack of concrete evidence we
see that the stories that are told match
the images of supposed aliens from
movies and from popular culture and many
are specifically debunked as aircraft or
weather balloon or birds or whatever so
you know there's that there's the lack
of physical evidence and all of these
different things so really funny Coda to
this which is Mark esper Trump's former
uh Secretary of Defense who says you
know if aliens were to come here I don't
think this is exactly what they would do
careful what
the aliens would travel across the
universe and all of a sudden decided to
come surveillance over Lake Huron in a
balloon moving 20 miles per hour that's
a plan that I think we're in good shape
and we now know we can shoot them down
but I I don't think that's true at all
look my hunch is that that these are
weather balloons or scientific
experiments put them off by another
country another com a company or some
non-profit we'll learn that in due
course yeah uh you know I it makes sense
esper is not a guy that I found super
interesting as an elected official or
whatever but I do think this is a good
point and it's similar to you know if if
the aliens really were making contact I
don't know that their priority would
necessarily be a anal probes and so it's
sort of weird that that's a big part of
a lot of the stories that are told I
think esper is right
but maybe that's just what the aliens
want us to think it's not us because we
would never just go 20 miles an hour
over one of the Great Lakes let me know
what you think I agree with Karine
Jean-Pierre and Kirby and esper I do not
believe this is evidence of alien
contact